A few years' back, John and his wife were driving back from a vacation in Concan, Texas. They had five kids in this van that they had rented for the trip, three of their own kids and then a couple of the neighbor's kids. They stopped at a taqueria in San Antonio for lunch, and then got back on the road. And John was feeling pretty good about things. All the kids seemed happy, nobody had gotten hurt on the vacation, lunch was really cheap, though he noticed he was getting some weird looks from other cars on the road. And then, outside Sealy, coming into the home stretch of the drive, he sees this Texas Highway Patrol car.
几年前，约翰和他的妻子开车从德克萨斯州康坎度假回来。他们租了一辆面包车，车上有五个孩子：三个是他们自己的，还有两个是邻居家的。他们在圣安东尼奥的一家塔可饼店吃了午饭，然后重新上路。约翰当时感觉很不错。孩子们看起来都很开心，度假期间没有人受伤，午饭也很便宜，尽管他注意到路上的其他车对他投来了一些奇怪的目光。然后，在希利外围，快到家的时候，他看到了这辆德克萨斯州公路巡逻车。
Pursuing me like an angry hornet. I've been pulled over before. This just felt different. I mean, it just kind of came out of nowhere and got on my tail and was just so aggressively driving. And I was totally bewildered.
像一只愤怒的马蜂一样追着我。我以前也被拦下过，但这感觉不一样。我的意思是，它突然从某个地方冒出来，跟在我后面，开得非常凶猛。我完全被搞糊涂了。
So he pulls over. And John says that, from watching the TV show Cops all these years, he knew that those two patrolmen are on, like, DEFCON 5. They are shouting at him over the patrol car's PA system.
于是他靠边停车了。约翰说，从多年观看电视节目《警察》(Cops)的经验来看，他知道那两名巡警当时处于 DEFCON 5 戒备状态。他们正在通过巡逻车的广播系统对他大喊大叫。
Neither one of them had gotten out of the car. I'm fairly sure I could already see a gun sticking out of the driver's side. And it was, you know, driver, with your left hand take your keys out of the ignition and put them on the hood. So of course I reach with my right hand, because that just seems impossible. And then, no, left hand. And you have to reach over the steering column and sort of put your hand upside down and then, like, get your hand out the window.
他们两个谁也没有下车。我很确定我当时已经能看到司机那边露出了一把枪。然后，你知道，就是“司机，用你的左手把钥匙从点火开关里拔出来，放在引擎盖上”。当然，我下意识想用右手去拿，因为用左手似乎不可能做到。然后，他们说，“不，用左手。”你必须伸过转向柱，把手翻转过来，然后把手伸出窗外。
And, I want to see your right hand while you're-- you know, and then it was clasp your hands behind your head, and with your left hand open the door, and then get on your knees. You just kind of just go to pot. You can't really follow all those instructions because you're confused, you don't know why this is happening to you.
而且，我还想在你要……你知道的时候看到你的右手，然后就是把双手抱在脑后，用左手打开车门，然后跪下。你整个人都有点崩溃了。你无法真正遵循所有这些指令，因为你很困惑，你不知道为什么会发生这种事。
You're freaking out a little bit.
你有点吓坏了。
You're freaking out a little bit. By this time, I'm on my knees in shorts on the gravel shoulder, and backing towards this car on my knees with my hands clasped behind my head.
你有点吓坏了。到这个时候，我正跪在碎石路肩上，穿着短裤，双手抱在脑后，跪着向那辆车倒退。
And he's thinking, maybe the car rental place got the paperwork messed up and reported the van is stolen, or maybe the cops thought they were smuggling people in from Mexico. They'd been so close to the border on their vacation. So, one of the cops comes out of the car and points a rifle at John's head, while the other one goes over to the van and starts asking a lot of questions of his wife, Jacqueline. And inside the van, of course the kids are terrified. His nine-year-old son is crying. And then, the cop who talked to Jacqueline now walks over to John, over on the shoulder of the road.
他当时在想，也许是租车公司弄错了文书工作，把这辆面包车报成了被盗车辆，或者警察以为他们在从墨西哥偷运人口。他们在度假时离边境太近了。所以，其中一名警察走下车，用步枪指着约翰的头，而另一名警察走到面包车旁，开始问他妻子杰奎琳很多问题。而在面包车里，孩子们当然吓坏了。他九岁的儿子在哭。然后，那个和杰奎琳谈话的警察现在朝约翰走过来，走到路肩上。
Well, he says, do you know what your daughter wrote on the car? I said no. And he told me that she'd written words to the effect that, please help me, we've been kidnapped, call 911. And he told me, he said, well, son, for 15 minutes there you were the most wanted man in Texas.
嗯，他说，“你知道你女儿在车上写了什么吗？”我说不知道。他告诉我，她写的字大意是：请救救我，我们被绑架了，请打911。他对我说了句，好吧，伙计，在那15分钟里，你是德克萨斯州最想被抓的人。
The exact wording, written in dust on the van's back window, was, help, please God, call 911, I've been kidnapped. And it wasn't John's daughter who wrote it. The cop said that it was Ingrid. The cop didn't know that that was one of the neighbor's kids. And John was so humiliated and frustrated, that when the cop asked him if he knew that what Ingrid did was against the law, John's response was, yeah, haul her in, prosecute her. Which they didn't do. Before long, John was back in the car and on the road.
写在面包车后窗灰尘上的确切措辞是：“救命，求求上帝，打911，我被绑架了。”写这些的并不是约翰的女儿。警察说那是英格丽德写的。警察不知道那是邻居家的孩子之一。约翰感到非常羞愧和沮丧，当警察问他是否知道英格丽德的行为是违法的时候，约翰的回答是：“是的，带走她，起诉她。”当然他们并没有那么做。没过多久，约翰就回到了车里，重新上路了。
And I'm just like, what the hell happened? I can't believe that you wrote that. And Ingrid, why did you do that? And then Ingrid was like, well, I didn't write all of it. I just wrote the part about call 911, and Malcolm was the one who wrote, I've been kidnapped.
我当时就想，这到底是怎么回事？我不敢相信你写了那个。还有英格丽德，你为什么要那么做？英格丽德说，嗯，我没有写全部。我只写了“打911”那部分，马尔科姆才是那个写“我被绑架了”的人。
And then, I'm like, well, who wrote the first thing on there. And Jacqueline was like, oh, well, that was me.
然后我就问，那上面第一行是谁写的。杰奎琳说，哦，那个啊，是我写的。
This is your wife?
这是你妻子？
Yes.
是的。
What did she write?
她写了什么？
She wrote, help me, please, because she'd been so stressed out by being with those kids, and she knew that she had an hour and a half or so in the car with them left to go before we could get home. So she had come out of the restaurant first and had just written, help me, please. And then, Malcolm came in and wrote, I've been kidnapped. And then, Ingrid came and put the little cherry on the top of what was to almost get me arrested or killed.
她写的是“救救我，求求你”，因为她被那些孩子搞得压力太大了，而且她知道在回家之前还要和他们在车里待一个半小时左右。所以她先从餐馆出来，就随手写了“救救我，求求你”。然后，马尔科姆进来写了“我被绑架了”。然后，英格丽德过来，给这一切加了最后一根稻草，差点让我被捕或丢了性命。
And I kept thinking that the story was going to be repeated to me as an urban legend at some cocktail party. Like, oh, did you hear about this guy who-- you know, he would end up getting shot or something and killed by the police.
我一直在想，这个故事会在某个鸡尾酒会上作为都市传说被传颂。就像，噢，你听说过那个家伙吗……你知道，他最后可能被警察枪杀什么的。
And now, I was going to say, in the urban legend version, you're dead, they shoot you.
我正想说，在都市传说版本里，你已经死了，他们开枪打死了你。
Yeah, totally. And then it would be pieced together and then I would haunt that section of highway.
对，完全是这样。然后这些线索会被拼凑起来，我就会在那段高速公路上闹鬼。
John Lomax, he hasn't been alive for 10 years.
约翰·洛马克斯，他已经死了10年了。
If anybody pulled over to make out there, I would come limping down the road with a hook on my arm or something.
如果有人靠边停车去亲热，我就会拖着断腿在路上走，手臂上还装个钩子什么的。
So, a bunch of kids dimed you out. Your own family dimed you out.
所以，是一群孩子出卖了你。你自己的家人出卖了你。
Yeah, and then I rolled over on them, just shamefully. That's the one thing I'm ashamed of is just urging that policeman to taking her to jail.
是的，然后我羞愧地把责任推给了他们。我最感到羞愧的一件事就是当时竟然催促警察把她带去坐牢。
You've heard the saying, a house divided against itself cannot stand.
你听说过那句谚语吧，分裂的家庭无法长存。
Yes. And that was a van divided against itself, and it didn't stand the trip from San Antonio to Houston.
是的。那是一辆分裂的面包车，它没能坚持住从圣安东尼奥到休斯顿的旅程。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. When you start throwing around the phrase, a house divided against itself cannot stand, you are trafficking in one of the most ominous and overwrought sayings in Western history.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》(This American Life)，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当你开始使用“分裂的家庭无法长存”这句话时，你就是在引用西方历史上最不祥、最夸张的俗语之一。
This is something that Abraham Lincoln warned on the eve of the Civil War. It's something that Jesus said when the Pharisees accused him of being in league with Satan. And today in our show, we have three stories where that weighty old saying actually describes things in our everyday lives, because the people in these stories really do seem like they're on the verge of disaster. We have a political story, we have a story of human anatomy, and we have a story of a family that just cannot seem to stay divorced, which, I know, sounds a little weird. Just stay with us.
这是亚伯拉罕·林肯在内战前夕发出的警告。这也是耶稣在法利赛人指责他与撒旦勾结时所说的话。在今天的节目中，我们有三个故事，这句沉重的老话确实描述了我们日常生活中的事情，因为故事中的人们看起来确实正处于灾难的边缘。我们有一个政治故事，一个关于人体构造的故事，还有一个关于一个似乎无法保持离婚状态的家庭的故事，我知道，这听起来有点奇怪。请继续收听。
Act One, War of Northern Aggression. It's a tough call these days, but if you're looking for the one state that more than any other is a house divided against itself, I would offer, for your consideration, Wisconsin. Of course, maybe you already know that. Maybe you saw the beginning of this, epic protests resisting Governor Scott Walker's budget cuts.
第一幕，北方侵略战争。如今很难下定论，但如果你要找一个最符合“分裂家庭”特征的州，我会提议考虑威斯康星州。当然，也许你已经知道了。也许你看到了这一切的开端，那些抵制斯科特·沃克州长预算削减的史诗级抗议活动。
And then, even more controversial, his legislation that blew a hole in collective bargaining rights for teachers' unions and all kinds of government employees. In the middle of all that, Democratic state senators fled to Illinois, where they stayed for three weeks trying to stall the bill.
然后，更具争议的是，他的立法削弱了教师工会和各种政府雇员的集体谈判权。在此期间，民主党州参议员逃往伊利诺伊州，他们在那里待了三周，试图阻挠这项法案。
Well, the latest-- and this part you might have missed-- is that the fight has not stopped. Walker's bill passed, but the feelings against it have split Wisconsin into a political civil war. The latest weapon of choice is this rarely used rule in the state's constitution that lets people knock politicians out of office. If you want to give somebody the boot, you collect signatures, and if you get enough-- and it takes a lot-- you can force any public official into a recall election, where they have to run again in the middle of their term. As of now, six Republican state senators and three Democratic state senators will face recall elections in the coming months.
好吧，最新的情况——你可能错过了这一点——是斗争并没有停止。沃克的法案通过了，但反对它的情绪将威斯康星州分裂成了一场政治内战。最新的选择性武器是州宪法中一项很少使用的规则，允许人们将政客罢免下台。如果你想把某人踢出局，你得收集签名，如果收集得足够多——这需要很多——你就可以强迫任何公职人员进行罢免选举，他们必须在任期中途再次参加竞选。目前，六名共和党州参议员和三名民主党州参议员将在未来几个月内面临罢免选举。
One of our producers, Ben Calhoun, recently went home to Wisconsin. He grew up there. He remembers getting dragged to his first political event by his parents when he was 10. And he spent a week traveling, talking to Democrats and Republicans around the state, which seems to be gradually losing its mind.
我们的制片人之一本·卡尔霍恩最近回到了威斯康星州。他在那里长大。他记得10岁时被父母带去参加他的第一次政治活动。他在那里待了一周，四处旅行，与全州的民主党人和共和党人交谈，这个州似乎正在逐渐失去理智。
You can't really understand how much Wisconsin politics has changed in the last year without seeing what it was like before all this. In early May, you could still spot old Wisconsin politics, the way it used to be. Early May was a big deadline for Wisconsin's recall war. Petitions were due, and so all across the state, Democrats and Republicans were out collecting signatures, trying to force politicians into recall elections.
如果不看看这一切之前是什么样子，你就无法真正理解过去一年威斯康星州的政治发生了多大变化。五月初，你仍然可以看到老派的威斯康星政治。五月初是威斯康星州罢免战争的一个重要截止日期。请愿书到期了，所以全州的民主党人和共和党人都在收集签名，试图迫使政客们进行罢免选举。
On a Saturday morning, I met up with these two women, these two friends, Betty Barns and Pam Packard. They were right where I was told they would be at 9:00 AM on Saturday, which was standing about 150 feet off a busy intersection in the empty parking lot of a doctor's office, next to a card table.
在一个周六早上，我见到了这两位女性，这两个朋友，贝蒂·巴恩斯和帕姆·帕卡德。她们就在我被告知她们会待的地方，周六上午9点，站在一个繁忙十字路口约150英尺外的一家医生办公室空旷的停车场里，旁边有一张卡片桌。
Every Saturday, yeah. Every night, 5:00 to 7:30. And then, Saturday, 9:00 to noon, we're here.
每个星期六，是的。每天晚上5点到7点半。然后，周六是9点到中午，我们都在这儿。
Oh, my gosh, you're here every night.
哦，天哪，你们每天晚上都在这儿。
Yes.
是的。
Every night. We've been here every night for two weeks.
每天晚上。我们两周来每天晚上都在这儿。
Wow, so you know this parking lot like nobody else.
哇，所以你对这个停车场比任何人都了解。
Yeah, we do.
是的，确实。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Rain, sleet, snow.
雨天、雨夹雪、下雪天。
Snow, yeah. We know it.
下雪天，是的。我们都领教过。
Betty and Pam were trying to collect enough signatures to force their state senator, a Democrat named Julie Lassa, into a recall election. Lassa was one of the 14 Democrats who fled Wisconsin trying to tie up Governor Scott Walker's anti-union legislation.
贝蒂和帕姆正在试图收集足够的签名来强迫她们的州参议员，一位名叫朱莉·拉萨的民主党人进行罢免选举。拉萨是那14名逃离威斯康星州试图阻挠斯科特·沃克州长反工会立法的民主党人之一。
Good morning.
早上好。
Hey.
嘿。
What was remarkable about Betty and Pam's set-up the day I was with them is just how much energy they'd spent making one of the most controversial moments in Wisconsin state politics, making it all as non-confrontational as possible. Part of it is just Betty and Pam's personalities. They're not yellers. They're 99% your grandma, 1% Sean Hannity.
我与贝蒂和帕姆在一起的那天，她们的布置引人注目之处在于，她们投入了多少精力让威斯康星州政治中最具争议的时刻之一尽可能地不带有对抗性。部分原因是贝蒂和帕姆的个性。她们不是大声喧哗的人。她们99%是你的祖母，1%是肖恩·汉尼提。
But there were other things. Like, for example, you know I said they were about 150 feet from the street? Well, Betty and Pam told me they deliberately set up in this parking lot away from the road, because, even though it made them harder to see, this was private property, and that way, if anyone wanted to come up and argue about what's happening, they could just tell them they had to leave.
但还有其他原因。例如，你知道我说她们离街道大约150英尺远吗？好吧，贝蒂和帕姆告诉我，她们故意在这个远离道路的停车场里设置摊位，因为即使这样让人们更难看到她们，但这是私有财产，这样如果有人想过来争论正在发生的事情，她们就可以告诉他们必须离开。
And while I was there, their strategy worked like a dream. All morning long, no confrontations to speak of, until the end of the day, when Pam and Betty were packing up to leave and this woman leaned out of a blue car that was passing by and yelled.
当我在那里的时候，她们的策略非常奏效。整个上午，几乎没有发生什么对抗，直到一天结束时，当帕姆和贝蒂收拾东西准备离开时，一个女人从一辆经过的蓝色轿车里探出身子大喊。
We love Julie Lassa.
我们爱朱莉·拉萨。
OK, it's very hard to hear. She was way out in the intersection. But what she yelled was, we love Julie Lassa. As in, that woman that you're trying to recall, we love her. I wondered what Pam and Betty would do. And then, for a surprisingly long time, they just didn't say anything, long enough that I started to wonder if they were going to pretend it hadn't happened at all.
好的，很难听清楚。她就在十字路口远处。但她喊的是：“我们爱朱莉·拉萨。”意思是，那个你们试图罢免的女人，我们爱她。我想知道帕姆和贝蒂会怎么做。然后，在一段令人惊讶的长久时间里，她们什么也没说，长到我开始怀疑她们是不是打算假装什么都没发生。
That's pretty typical.
这很典型。
The yelling?
那个大喊大叫？
Yeah.
是的。
What were they yelling?
她们在喊什么？
We love Julie Lassa.
我们爱朱莉·拉萨。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
[听不清]。
Yeah. I don't dislike her. She's a great mom.
是的。我不讨厌她。她是个伟大的母亲。
This is what I'm getting at. This was as harsh as it got. All morning, on the front lines of the most heated, intense political fight Wisconsin has seen in years, and this was it. You have someone heckling by saying they love someone, and then Betty saying, I don't dislike her, I think she's a good mom.
这就是我想表达的。这就是最激烈的程度了。整个上午，在威斯康星州多年来见过的最激烈、最紧张的政治斗争前线，这就是全部了。有人通过说她们爱某人来进行嘲讽，然后贝蒂说，我不讨厌她，我认为她是个好母亲。
That's the Wisconsin politics I know. Because, having talked to Betty for more than an hour and listened to her complain about Julie Lassa and the Democrats to her friends and neighbors, frowning and saying things like dereliction of duty and there need to be consequences, I know that what Betty was feeling inside probably went something more like this: I think Julie Lassa is a terrible state senator, one of those despicable Democrats who fled the state, shrugged off the responsibility to stay and vote in the minority, and take the political beating I think she deserves, and now I want to punish her, so badly, in fact, that I'm willing to stand here, here in this cold fricking parking lot every night, and every Saturday morning, just to make that happen.
这就是我所知道的威斯康星政治。因为，在与贝蒂交谈了一个多小时，听她向朋友和邻居抱怨朱莉·拉萨和民主党人，皱着眉头说出诸如“失职”和“必须有后果”之类的话后，我知道贝蒂内心深处的感觉可能更像这样：我认为朱莉·拉萨是个糟糕的州参议员，是那些逃离本州、推卸留在少数派阵营投票责任、逃避我所认为她应得的政治打击的可鄙的民主党人之一，现在我想惩罚她，事实上严重到我愿意站在这个冰冷该死的停车场里，每天晚上，还有每个周六早上，只为了让这一切发生。
But that wasn't what she said. What she said was, I think she's a good mom. In Wisconsin, traditionally, you might disagree about politics, and you might get worked up, but for the most part it's not something you go to war with your neighbor about. Being civil is more important. All the screaminess of our national politics, you try to avoid that. And at the very least, you don't let it show. But that's the old Wisconsin.
但她说的不是这些。她说的是，我觉得她是个好母亲。在威斯康星州，传统上，你可能在政治上意见不合，你可能会很激动，但在大多数情况下，这不是你会与邻居开战的事情。保持文明更重要。我们全国政治中所有的喧嚣，你都会尽量避免。而且至少，你不会表现出来。但那是旧的威斯康星。
And spending time in my home state recently, with Democrats trying to recall Republicans, Republicans trying to recall Democrats, I saw something that was unfamiliar, an anger that's infected the entire state. As far as I know, there isn't a good way to measure pure anger. But I'll tell you one rising indicator, and this is one pollsters don't usually count, I can tell you, without question, the use of the middle finger in Wisconsin politics is way up. On sidewalks and in parking lots across the entire state, people are flipping each other off at alarming rates. And the trend is bipartisan.
最近在我家乡待了一段时间，看到民主党人试图罢免共和党人，共和党人试图罢免民主党人，我看到了不熟悉的东西，一种感染了整个州的愤怒。据我所知，没有测量纯粹愤怒的好方法。但我可以告诉你一个上升的指标，这是民意调查人员通常不会统计的，我可以毫不含糊地告诉你，威斯康星州政治中中指的使用率正在大幅上升。在全州的人行道和停车场里，人们正以惊人的频率向对方竖中指。而且这种趋势是跨党派的。
This brings me to this short video that I saw. You can watch this thing yourself if you want. It's on YouTube. It's a video of the campaign announcement. Quick background, on March 9, a Republican state senator named Luther Olsen voted in favor of Governor Walker's bill that attacked collective bargaining. Because of that, Democrats decided they were going to take Luther down.
这让我想到了我看到的这个短视频。如果你愿意，你可以自己看这个视频。它在 YouTube 上。这是一个竞选公告的视频。简单背景，3月9日，一位名叫卢瑟·奥尔森的共和党州参议员投票支持沃克州长攻击集体谈判的法案。正因为如此，民主党人决定要打倒卢瑟。
They organized a petition drive, filed thousands of signatures, and successfully forced Luther into a recall election this summer. Enter a Democratic state representative named Fred Clark, who announced he was going to challenge Olsen, try to knock him out of office. The video that I saw that caught my attention was of Fred announcing that he was running, which he did on April 21.
他们组织了请愿运动，提交了数千份签名，并成功地迫使卢瑟在今年夏天进行了罢免选举。登场的是一位名叫弗雷德·克拉克的民主党州众议员，他宣布要挑战奥尔森，试图让他下台。我看到的那个引起我注意的视频是弗雷德宣布他要参选的视频，他在4月21日做了这件事。
OK, OK, so let's get this rolling and then we can pause it whenever you have a point where you want to explain what's going on in the room.
好的，好的，让我们开始播放，然后每当你想要解释房间里发生的事情时，我们随时可以暂停。
Fred and I watched this video together in his home office, the office where Fred runs his forestry business. To get to it, we had to go through the first floor, which has more than half a dozen chainsaws hanging from the ceiling.
弗雷德和我在他的家庭办公室一起看了这个视频，这是弗雷德经营他的林业业务的办公室。为了到达那里，我们不得不穿过一楼，那里悬挂着十几把电锯。
Fred explained that he decided to make his campaign announcement in his home town of 12,000, Baraboo, Wisconsin. For a location, he picked the town civic center, which used to be a school. So picture a classroom. Fred's standing in front of a chalkboard behind a lectern. Fred's tall and skinny, with a neatly trimmed beard that's turning gray. As he gets ready to speak, he has glasses hanging around his neck by a string, and they make him look more like a high school history teacher and less like a guy who runs a forestry business.
弗雷德解释说，他决定在家乡巴拉布（人口12,000）宣布竞选。地点他选在了城镇市民中心，那里以前是一所学校。所以想象一个教室。弗雷德站在讲台后面的黑板前。弗雷德又高又瘦，留着修剪整齐的胡子，胡子正在变灰。在他准备讲话时，他的眼镜用一根绳子挂在脖子上，这让他看起来更像一个高中历史老师，而不像一个经营林业生意的人。
I have to say, from the first time I saw this video, even the first 30 seconds of cheering sounded kind of weird.
我必须说，从我第一次看这个视频开始，即使是前30秒的欢呼声也听起来有点奇怪。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Are those boos that are in the background?
背景里那是嘘声吗？
No, at that point you're hearing cheering and clapping.
不，在那一点你听到的是欢呼声和掌声。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
And as I opened it up, I wasn't even aware that there were Olsen supporters in the room at that point.
当我开始的时候，我甚至不知道房间里当时有奥尔森的支持者。
By Olsen supporters, Fred means people who support the Republican he's trying to knock out of office, people who'd come there that day to Fred's announcement, not to cheer, but to heckle. Fred says they were hard to see from where he was, but in the video, the camera pans back across the crowd.
奥尔森的支持者，弗雷德指的是那些支持他试图让其下台的共和党人的人，他们那天来到弗雷德的宣布会现场，不是为了欢呼，而是为了干扰。弗雷德说从他所在的地方很难看到他们，但在视频中，摄像机扫过了人群。
There's another one there. There's one there.
那里还有一个。那里有一个。
Oh, wait, so you're pointing to--?
哦，等等，所以你在指——？
Yep. So back in here, the number of the Olsen supporters that have come in have started raising Olsen signs. It looks like, let's see, they've got a couple of his old yard signs they pulled up, and then some handmade signs. That was my first clue that these guys had kind of worked their way into the room and the fun was going to start.
是的。所以在这里面，进来的奥尔森支持者的数量开始举起奥尔森的标语牌。看起来，让我们看看，他们带了几块他以前的院子标语牌，还有一些手工制作的标语牌。那是我的第一个线索，说明这些人已经混进房间里，好戏要开始了。
At first, it seems like just a little booing and jeering. But pretty soon, you can hear people really start yelling at each other. While things get rowdier, Fred's up front trying to soldier through his speech. Eventually, people start pleading with each other to stop, including Fred, who looks a little bewildered. One woman yells, we're nice in Wisconsin.
起初，看起来只是一点嘘声和嘲笑。但很快，你能听到人们真正开始互相大喊大叫。当事情变得更吵闹时，弗雷德在前台试图坚持完成他的演讲。最终，人们开始恳求彼此停止，包括弗雷德，他看起来有点困惑。一个女人大喊：“我们在威斯康星人是友好的。”
We're nice in Wisconsin.
我们在威斯康星人是友好的。
All right, let's be respectful, please.
好吧，请尊重一点。
Be civil.
保持文明。
We've got over 850 volunteers, work seven days a week in one of the worse springs in recent memory.
我们有超过850名志愿者，在近期记忆中最糟糕的春天之一里，每周工作七天。
Are people just kind of shouting at each other right there?
人们就在那里互相大喊大叫吗？
Yeah. Yeah, I think, at that point, there's been some jostling. Olsen supporters had started to whistle and yell, and some of our supporters were asking them to be quiet. And that's when the air in the room started to get a little thick.
是的。是的，我想在这一点上，发生了一些推搡。奥尔森的支持者开始吹口哨和大喊，我们的一些支持者要求他们安静。就在那时，房间里的气氛开始变得有些凝重。
From there, it got worse, particularly when a friend of Fred's, a guy named Chuck, he started taking pictures of some of the Republicans. He was pointing his camera at one of them, and the person he was taking the picture stuck out a sign to block the shot. Chuck raised the camera higher.
从那里开始情况变得更糟，特别是当弗雷德的一个朋友，一个叫查克的人，开始给一些共和党人拍照。他把相机对准其中一个人，那个人伸出一个标语牌来挡住镜头。查克把相机举得更高。
And then, at that point, somebody just reached out and grabbed it by the lens and pulled it down. And I'm not sure if it hit the floor or pulled the lens off, but at that point you hear Chuck saying, you broke my camera.
然后，就在那一刻，有人伸手抓住镜头把它拉了下来。我不确定它是撞到了地板还是把镜头拽下来了，但那一刻你听到查克说：“你弄坏了我的相机。”
You broke my camera.
你弄坏了我的相机。
[YELLING]
[大喊声]
That's the point when my friend, Homer, who's a pretty big fellow but very gentle man, decided that the thing for him to do was climb on a table so he could see what was happening, just in case it became important later. I think that was a trigger for the Olsen supporters to start shouting at me and interrupting me and--
那是我朋友荷马决定爬上桌子的时刻，他是个大块头但非常温柔的人，他觉得他该做的事就是爬到桌子上，这样他就能看清发生了什么，以防以后变得很重要。我想那是奥尔森支持者开始对我大喊大叫并打断我发言的触发点，而且——
The rest of the 12-minute video's all like this, the Olsen supporters heckling, the Clark supporters trying to shout the hecklers down, some people pleading for it all to stop, and Fred Clark just looking kind of flustered. Remember, this isn't a presidential rally, a race for US Senate, or even congressional representatives, where this would all still seem a little weird. This is a race for the Wisconsin state legislature. Do you even know who your state senator is? Me neither.
12分钟视频的其余部分都是这样，奥尔森的支持者在干扰，克拉克支持者试图大声盖过干扰者，有些人恳求这一切停止，而弗雷德·克拉克看起来有点惊慌失措。记住，这甚至不是总统集会，不是美国参议院竞选，甚至不是国会代表竞选，在那些场合这看起来仍然有点奇怪。这是一场威斯康星州议会的竞选。你甚至知道你的州参议员是谁吗？我也一样。
The craziest thing, something you'd never know just watching this online, is just how close everyone in the room is personally, like in their personal lives, when they weren't shouting at each other like this.
最疯狂的事情，你在网上看这个视频永远不会知道的事情，是房间里的每个人在个人层面上是多么亲近，也就是说，当他们不像这样互相大喊大叫时，他们在个人生活中。
What percentage of the people do you know in the room?
你认识房间里百分之多少的人？
There's Charlie Bradley. There's Roger Springman. There's Ed and Jill Brennan. I probably personally know 75% of the people in the room.
那是查理·布拉德利。那是罗杰·斯普林曼。那是埃德和吉尔·布伦南。我可能亲自认识房间里75%的人。
Did you know any of the Olsen supporters who were there? Did you recognize anyone?
你认识那里的任何奥尔森支持者吗？你认出了任何人吗？
Yeah, and that's really the interesting part of it to me. I knew a number of them.
是的，这对我来说是最有趣的部分。我认识其中的不少人。
Fred says, among the people harassing him, there were some people he wasn't surprised to see. There was the head of the county Tea Party, who Fred says he got along OK with in the past, but he wasn't shocked to see him. But there were others, like a school board member, someone he knows pretty well, someone he sat down and talked to a lot of times. There was a county supervisor who Fred also knows pretty well.
弗雷德说，在骚扰他的人中，有一些人他并不惊讶会看到。有县茶党的负责人，弗雷德说他过去和那人相处得还行，所以他不惊讶看到他。但还有其他人，比如一个校董会成员，他非常了解的人，他曾坐下来谈过很多次的人。还有一个他也很了解的县主管。
I think most interesting was my own town chairman, here in a rural township, was there protesting. And this is a fellow who I've known for years, who'd been a supporter of mine previously, and who I've worked with on a number of issues, including an issue having to do with flooding on a local creek.
我想最有趣的是我自己的城镇主席，在一个农村乡镇，也在抗议。这是一个我认识多年的伙伴，以前曾是我的支持者，我在许多问题上和他合作过，包括一个与当地小溪洪水有关的问题。
Did you get that? This guy that Fred's talking about was a political ally, a former supporter, who'd come out that day to heckle.
听到了吗？弗雷德谈论的这个家伙曾经是政治盟友，以前的支持者，那天出来干扰他。
Yeah, yeah. And I think that's a clue to where we are right now.
是的，是的。我想这就是我们现在所处位置的一个线索。
And now, get this. Fred didn't used to just get along politically with some of the Olsen supporters who are now screaming at him, he used to get along with Luther Olsen, the Republican he's now challenging. They had their political differences, but according to both of them, they like each other, think the other's a good public servant, and that they're easy to work with even though they're from opposing parties.
现在，听着。弗雷德以前不仅在政治上与一些现在对他尖叫的奥尔森支持者相处得很好，他还曾与卢瑟·奥尔森（他现在挑战的共和党人）相处得很好。他们有政治分歧，但据他们两人说，他们互相喜欢，认为对方是好的公职人员，并且认为他们很容易合作，尽管他们来自对立的政党。
Matter of fact, the morning Scott Walker unveiled his anti-union legislation, Luther Olsen and Fred Clark were doing an event together. They were both shocked. Luther, the Republican, even called Walker's idea radical. But eventually, under a lot of pressure, Luther caved, fell in line with his party, and voted with the governor. And that vote drew a line between Fred and Luther.
事实上，斯科特·沃克公布他反工会立法的那天早上，卢瑟·奥尔森和弗雷德·克拉克正在一起参加活动。他们都感到震惊。共和党人卢瑟甚至称沃克的想法是激进的。但最终，在巨大压力下，卢瑟屈服了，与党派保持一致，并投票支持州长。那张选票在弗雷德和卢瑟之间画出了一条界线。
I think Luther's the same guy. I think I'm the same guy. We're just in a very different environment right now. And this is an environment that is testing the character of anybody who's in elected office today. I like Luther personally. And in any environment that you might call normal, Luther and I could get along just fine. And in fact, a lot of people have supported both of us and appreciated the fact that we work together across the aisle as well as we do.
我认为卢瑟还是同一个人。我认为我也是同一个人。我们现在只是处于一个非常不同的环境中。这是一个正在考验今天任何在职民选官员性格的环境。我个人喜欢卢瑟。在任何你可以称之为正常的环境中，卢瑟和我都可以相处得很好。事实上，很多人同时支持我们两人，并感谢我们跨党派合作得如此之好。
So you know of people who would cast a vote for you and vote for Luther in an election.
所以你认识会在选举中投票给你又投票给卢瑟的人。
Oh, I know hundreds of them.
哦，我认识成百上千个这样的人。
Do you feel like the two of you-- and not just the two of you, but like, all the people in this room-- kind of got drafted into a situation that wasn't one of your making?
你觉得你们两个——不仅是你们两个，还有房间里的所有人——是被卷入了一个不是你们制造的局面中吗？
I agree with that. I think what people are wondering about right now is, where's the Wisconsin that we knew?
我同意这一点。我想人们现在在问的是，我们认识的那个威斯康星州在哪里？
I told Fred Clark, in my whole life I'd never seen anything like this in Wisconsin politics. And he told me people have been comparing this to the Vietnam War protests, which raises a question. A lot of controversial stuff has happened between the Vietnam War and today, so why was it this issue that's turned the state into a political bloodbath?
我告诉弗雷德·克拉克，我这一生从未在威斯康星政治中见过这样的事情。他告诉我人们一直在将此与越南战争抗议进行比较，这就提出了一个问题。在越南战争到今天之间发生了许多有争议的事情，那么为什么是这个问题将本州变成了政治血洗呢？
Wisconsin's a big rural state, but it's not conservative. Its politics are in the middle, leaning a little towards the left. Organized labor has a long history in the state, and Wisconsin's gone Democratic in every presidential election since Reagan. But bottom line, it's moderate, polite, and civil, and moderate. That right there is really the break Scott Walker has made.
威斯康星州是一个大农村州，但它并不保守。它的政治处于中间，稍微向左倾斜。有组织劳工在该州有着悠久的历史，而且自里根以来，威斯康星州在每次总统选举中都投给了民主党。但归根结底，它是温和、礼貌和文明的。那一点确实是斯科特·沃克所做的决裂。
His plan, whether you love it or you hate it, was a big move away from the middle. He's pulled a pretty moderate state dramatically towards an extreme, and done something they don't do in Wisconsin. He's picked a fight. And he's forced a lot of people who don't like to fight to choose sides anyway. I can't tell you how many stories I heard about people collecting recall signatures on both sides getting harassed.
他的计划，无论你是喜欢还是讨厌，都是远离中间路线的一大举措。他把一个相当温和的州急剧推向极端，并做了他们在威斯康星州不做的事情。他挑起了一场争斗。他迫使许多不喜欢争斗的人无论如何都要选边站队。我无法告诉你我听到了多少关于双方收集罢免签名的人被骚扰的故事。
I heard about a guy who got punched by someone who then tried to take his clipboard. Democrats in Milwaukee suburbs told me, while they were collecting on the side of the road, they had several people in cars swerve towards them, hit the gas, and then swerve away at the last minute.
我听说一个家伙被某人打了一拳，那个人随后试图抢走他的剪贴板。密尔沃基郊区的民主党人告诉我，当他们在路边收集签名时，有几个人开车冲向他们，踩油门，然后在最后一刻转向躲开。
How many did you end up getting?
你最终收集了多少？
23,300.
23,300。
And you needed, originally?
原本需要多少？
15,960.
15,960。
Oh, wow. So that's, I mean--
哦，哇。所以那，我是说——
Yep, we did it.
是的，我们做到了。
This is Kim Simac. She spent a couple months organizing a recall campaign that landed 23,000 signatures. It was against her state senator, a Democrat, one of 14 who fled to Illinois.
这是金·西马克。她花了几个月时间组织了一场罢免运动，获得了23,000个签名。那是针对她的州参议员，一位民主党人，那14个逃往伊利诺伊州的人之一。
That bothered me a lot.
那让我很困扰。
When I talked to Kim, I asked her if things in her part of the state had turned personal. She took me into her kitchen.
当我与金交谈时，我问她所在州的情况是否变得个人化了。她带我进了她的厨房。
Some of the nasty stuff, what I did was--
一些讨厌的东西，我所做的是——
So you just have this on your fridge?
所以你把这些贴在冰箱上？
Yeah. Here's one of your classy ones.
是的。这是你们其中一个有品位的。
To collect signatures, Kim had mailed petitions out to people in the district. And under a magnet on her refrigerator, she had a stack that had come back to her with angry messages on them. Kim didn't seem super eager to read them to me, which is how I learned that it feels very, very awkward to read someone else's hate mail out loud to them.
为了收集签名，金把请愿书邮寄给了选区的人。在冰箱的一个磁铁下面，她有一叠寄回给她的带有愤怒留言的请愿书。金似乎不太热衷于读给我听，这就是我了解到大声向别人读出他们的仇恨邮件是非常、非常尴尬的事情。
Come to my house for a signature. Go [BLEEP] yourselves. Go [BLEEP] yourself, you [BLEEP] suckers. How dare you send [BLEEP] to my house. So they mailed this back to you?
“到我家来要签名。去[消音]你们自己。去[消音]你自己，你这个[消音]混蛋。怎么敢寄[消音]到我家。”所以他们把这个寄回给你了？
Mmm-hmm. We were going to put a big mural together, kind of fun, and put it on Facebook. And then afterwards, it just got to be not so funny anymore. And so, we just--
嗯哼。我们本来打算做一张大壁画，挺好玩的，然后发到 Facebook 上。但后来，它就变得不那么好笑了。所以，我们只是——
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
Yeah, that's not a nice one.
是的，那不是一个好的。
All this hostility, it isn't just people at rallies and protests. It's seeped down into the groundwater of everyday life. Kim says it's not just anonymous mail. She's lost friends over this, good friends. She's lived in this place for a long time. She raised nine kids here, but she says it all feels different now.
所有这些敌意，不仅仅是集会和抗议中的人。它已经渗透到了日常生活的地下水中。金说这不仅仅是匿名邮件。她因此失去了朋友，好朋友。她在这个地方住了很长时间。她在这里抚养了九个孩子，但她说现在一切感觉都不同了。
Well, I mean, at the post office, at the grocery store, I've had people waiting at the end of my driveway for me that are-- it's scary. We have cameras on the driveway now. I mean, all of that, that's all ugly. I sent nine kids to this school here, and I've had quite a few of the teachers-- I mean, I had one flip me off recently. It was like, OK.
嗯，我是说，在邮局，在杂货店，我遇到过有人在我的车道尽头等我，他们是——这很吓人。我们现在的车道上有摄像头。我是说，所有这些，那都是丑陋的。我把九个孩子送到这所学校，我遇到过不少老师——我是说，我最近有一个老师对我竖中指。这就像，好吧。
Kim says one of the teachers at the school she mentioned, the one where she sent all of her kids, a teacher there put together a list of businesses that people should boycott. Kim and her husband, who own a horse stable in a camp, were at the top of the list. Also, the recall Kim organized against her state senator, a Democrat named Jim Holperin, it was also personal.
金说她提到的学校里的其中一位老师，那个她把所有孩子都送去的地方，那里的一位老师整理了一份人们应该抵制的企业名单。金和她拥有马厩和营地的丈夫排在名单的首位。此外，金组织针对她的州参议员（一位名叫吉姆·霍尔佩林的民主党人）的罢免活动，也是个人化的。
For Kim, Jim Holperin wasn't just a name on a ballot. He went to the same school as her husband, and they run into each other in town, though Kim says the two of them haven't spoken in the last few years, since she started an argument about global warming when they ran into each other at their local post office.
对金来说，吉姆·霍尔佩林不仅仅是选票上的名字。他和她丈夫上同一所学校，他们在镇上会碰到，尽管金说他们俩在过去几年里没有说过话，自从她在当地邮局偶遇时引发了一场关于全球变暖的争论之后。
Kim and Jim's situation is surprising because of who Jim Holperin is. Jim was actually one of the very first state senators in Wisconsin targeted for recall. And if you met Jim Holperin on the street, that just might blow your mind. Jim Holperin is clean-cut, gray-haired, reserved, and nice. If you lived in a town called This Guy Will Never Be Controversial, Jim would be your state senator. And he would never, ever be holding in his hand an email that ended like this.
金和吉姆的情况令人惊讶，因为吉姆·霍尔佩林是谁。吉姆实际上是威斯康星州第一批被罢免的州参议员之一。如果你在街上见到吉姆·霍尔佩林，那可能会让你大吃一惊。吉姆·霍尔佩林外表整洁、白发苍苍、矜持且友好。如果你住在一个叫“这个人永远不会引起争议”的城镇，吉姆会是你的州参议员。他永远不会手里拿着一封以这样结尾的电子邮件：
Your ads on TV are a fricking joke. You ran instead of standing up for your constituents. You have no clue what hardworking people even are, you egotistical bureaucrat and useless piece-of-crap politician. Just want to let you know how the majority of us that really work and pay taxes in this state feel about you and the other idiots that are trying to bankrupt us. Good luck getting a real job after you get recalled, you jackwad. Sincerely, Feel You Are Completely Worthless, Bruce.
“你电视上的广告简直是笑话。你逃跑了，而不是为你的选民站出来。你这个自负的官僚和毫无用处的烂政治家，根本不知道什么叫辛勤工作的人。只想让你知道我们这些在这个州真正工作和纳税的大多数人对你和其他试图让我们破产的白痴的看法。祝你在被罢免后能找到一份真正的工作，你这个笨蛋。真诚地，觉得你完全一文不值的布鲁斯。”
When Walker's legislation came down the pipe, and Jim fled to Illinois with the other Dems, Jim says the phone calls he was getting were 75% against him, but the letters were 75% for him. Some people called him a jackwad. Some people called him a hero. Jim says he doesn't feel like either. Jim says he feels like what he's always been, a conservative Democrat, a moderate, a guy from the middle. And that's what makes this all so strange to him.
当沃克的立法下达时，吉姆与其他民主党人逃往伊利诺伊州，吉姆说他接到的电话75%是反对他的，但信件75%是支持他的。有些人称他为笨蛋。有些人称他为英雄。吉姆说他感觉自己哪一个都不是。吉姆说他感觉自己还是他一直以来的那个人，一个保守的民主党人，一个温和派，一个来自中间地带的人。而这就是这一切对他来说如此奇怪的原因。
I've been viewed, I think and I hope, over the years as being a somewhat reasonable guy. Well, on this issue, we've got a divisiveness in this state that starts at the family level and goes to the community level and goes right up to the state level. But the outcome of all that is it's made a guy like me, who liked to think of himself as reasonable, and I hope was maybe perceived as reasonable and someone independent, it's made me seem unreasonable, unwilling to compromise, and someone who is dug in and unwilling to listen. That's disturbing to me personally, and it's the most disturbing part of this whole thing.
多年来，我想而且我希望，我一直被视为一个相当理智的人。好吧，在这个问题上，我们在这个州有一种分裂，从家庭层面开始，延伸到社区层面，一直到州层面。但这一切的结果是，它让像我这样的人——一个喜欢自认为理智，且我希望也许被视为理智且独立的人——看起来不理智，不愿妥协，一个固执己见、不愿倾听的人。这让我个人感到不安，这是整件事中最令人不安的部分。
As election time for the recalls has gotten closer, things have gotten more outrageous. The GOP decided to run fake Democrats in the recall elections to confuse Democratic voters, but more importantly, to trigger Democratic primaries, which will put off the moment when Republicans face Democrats, presumably to give them more time to campaign and boost their poll numbers. Putting fake candidates on ballots is the kind of dirty tactic that's not unheard of, though when it's used it's frowned on, so nobody would admit to it publicly.
随着罢免选举时间的临近，事情变得越来越离谱。共和党决定在罢免选举中派出假民主党人，以混淆民主党选民，但更重要的是，为了触发民主党初选，这将推迟共和党人面对民主党人的时刻，推测是为了给他们更多的时间竞选并提高他们的民调数字。把假候选人放在选票上是那种并不罕见的不光彩战术，尽管当它被使用时会受到谴责，所以没有人会公开承认这一点。
In Wisconsin, it's become so us-versus-them that the Wisconsin Republican Party is openly admitting that they're doing this, that they are behind the fake Democrats on the ballot. Meantime, worried that they might lose their majority in the Senate, the state Republican Party battened down its hatches and started fast-tracking a bunch of controversial bills through the legislature. Democrats, unable to stop them, have gotten extreme, too.
在威斯康星州，情况变得如此“我们对他们”，以至于威斯康星共和党公开承认他们正在这样做，他们是选票上假民主党人的幕后推手。同时，担心他们可能会失去参议院的多数席位，州共和党收紧防线，开始在立法机关快速推进一堆有争议的法案。无法阻止他们的民主党人也变得极端了。
Even though the crowds at the Capitol aren't what they were, the other day two protesters opposing Governor Walker's budget used those heavy, U-shaped bike locks to lock their throats to the railing of the Wisconsin state Senate. One of them told police officers he'd swallowed the key.
尽管国会大厦的人群不如以前了，但前几天两名反对沃克州长预算的抗议者使用那些沉重的U型自行车锁把他们的喉咙锁在威斯康星州参议院的栏杆上。其中一人告诉警察他已经吞下了钥匙。
Talking to Wisconsin politicians about what's happening, I often got this nagging feeling that this is all very disorienting. And eventually, I realized it's because they built their careers in a political environment where diplomacy matters, and suddenly they're fighting for those careers in a place where the rules have changed. The thing about a big move like Walker's, it can take a place where people value meeting in the middle and compromise and turn it into a place where everything is black and white. And in a black-and-white world, the people like Jim Holperin, who like grey, they become outcasts, and they risk getting attacked from both sides.
与威斯康星政客谈论正在发生的事情时，我经常有这种令人烦恼的感觉，这一切非常令人困惑。最终，我意识到这是因为他们的职业生涯建立在一个外交非常重要的政治环境中，而突然之间，他们正在规则已经改变的地方为这些职业生涯而战。沃克那样的大动作的问题在于，它可以把一个人们重视寻求中间立场和妥协的地方变成一个一切非黑即白的地方。而在一个非黑即白的世界里，像吉姆·霍尔佩林这样喜欢灰色的人变成了被排斥者，并且面临着来自双方的攻击。
I didn't just get that feeling from Democrats like Jim Holperin, the guy with the jackwad email, I heard it from moderate Republicans, too. State Senator Luther Olsen, the Republican whose supporters stirred up trouble in that video you heard, Olsen said something to me just like Jim. He said, when Walker unveiled his controversial legislation, Luther reached out to his Republican colleagues to offer a compromise, an olive branch. But there was so much pressure from Walker that the middle ground vanished. Those were his words. The middle ground vanished.
我不仅从像吉姆·霍尔佩林（那个收到笨蛋邮件的家伙）那样的民主党人那里得到这种感觉，我也从温和的共和党人那里听到了。州参议员卢瑟·奥尔森（那个支持者在视频中闹事的共和党人），奥尔森说的话和吉姆很像。他说，当沃克公布他有争议的立法时，卢瑟联系了他的共和党同僚提供妥协，一种橄榄枝。但来自沃克的压力太大，以至于中间立场消失了。这是他的原话。中间立场消失了。
Before Luther knew it, he was being recalled, and Fred Clark was challenging him for his office. And their race kind of sums up what's going on, because in any other election, Fred and Luther would be a moderate Democrat against a moderate Republican. But in the recall election this summer, it will be the guy who voted with Scott Walker and the guy who voted against him.
在卢瑟意识到之前，他已经被罢免了，弗雷德·克拉克正在挑战他的职位。他们的竞选总结了正在发生的事情，因为在任何其他选举中，弗雷德和卢瑟会是一个温和的民主党人对阵一个温和的共和党人。但在今年夏天的罢免选举中，它将是一个投票支持斯科特·沃克的家伙和投票反对他的家伙。
Ben Calhoun. He's one of the producers of our show.
本·卡尔霍恩。他是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - "THE ONE ON THE RIGHT IS ON THE LEFT" BY JOHNNY CASH]
[音乐 - 约翰尼·卡什演唱的“右边那个在左边” (The One on the Right Is on the Left)]
Coming up, the laziest organ in your body takes a stand against the others. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，你身体里最懒的器官对其他器官采取了立场。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, A House Divided. We have stories of internal strife with possible dire consequences. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, Split a Gut.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，并带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“分裂的家庭”。我们有关于内部纷争可能带来可怕后果的故事。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“肠道分裂”。
Comedian Julian McCullough tells a story on stage about this night when he suddenly had this urgent, explosive feeling in his gut. He assumed food poisoning, and so he asked his friend, Sean, to drive him home.
喜剧演员朱利安·麦卡洛在舞台上讲述了一个故事，关于他突然感到肠子有一种紧急、爆炸性感觉的那个晚上。他认为是食物中毒，于是请他的朋友肖恩开车送他回家。
So we get in his car. He's driving me to my apartment across town. And he could tell that I'm getting worse. Like, I'm starting to sweat a little bit. I'm kind of slouched over in the seat. And he's like, man, you don't look so good. Do you want me to come up to your apartment and make sure you're OK? And I was thinking about my apartment, which is a place where you can see the stove and the toilet from the bed. And I was like, that's not a big enough apartment for what's about to happen.
我们上了他的车。他开车送我回家。他能看出我越来越难受。我是说，我开始流汗。我瘫在座位上。他说，伙计，你看上去不太好。要我上去确保你没事吗？我在想我的公寓，那是一个从床上就能看到炉子和厕所的地方。我想，那间公寓对于接下来要发生的事情来说太小了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So I was like, no, thank you for the nicest and grossest offer you've ever given me. I will do this alone. So I get upstairs to my apartment. I immediately take all my clothes off, which I do every time I come home. But like, I really did it this time. So I'm naked in my apartment, and the problem is that I am still in a great deal of pain but I don't feel an urge to use the bathroom.
所以我说，不，谢谢你给出过最贴心也最恶心的提议。我会独自处理。于是我上了楼。我立刻把衣服全脱了，每次回家我都这么做。但这次我真的是彻底脱了。所以我赤身裸体在公寓里，问题是虽然我仍然感到非常痛苦，但我没有上厕所的冲动。
So I just decide, OK, it's going to take a little longer. So I go into my room, and eventually, I can't get comfortable anymore in any position. I can't lay down. I can't stretch my body out. I haven't stretched my body out straight in about 45 minutes to an hour.
所以我决定，好吧，还需要一点时间。于是我进了房间，最终，我无法在任何姿势下感到舒服。我不能躺下。我不能伸展身体。我已经大约45分钟到一个小时没有伸展身体了。
So somehow my body and the pain in my body negotiate a truce where, if I am in a prayer position on the floor next to my bed and with my arms on my bed, we can deal. I'm like, this is weird that I'm being forced into a prayer position, but I'm not going to overthink it. So I'm in this prayer position for about another 45 minutes, and my entire stomach is killing me.
所以不知何故，我的身体和痛苦达成了休战，如果我以祈祷的姿势跪在床边的地板上，双臂搁在床上，我就能应付。我想，这很奇怪，我被迫进入祈祷姿势，但我不想想太多。所以我在这个祈祷姿势里又待了大约45分钟，整个胃痛得要命。
And I'm freaking out. And basically, I don't want to call 911 or go to the emergency room. I grew up in a family without health insurance my whole life, and our policy was generally, give it a couple weeks. So I didn't have health insurance.
我快吓坏了。基本上，我不想打911或去急诊室。我成长在一个家里没有健康保险的家庭，我们的政策通常是：过几周再说。所以我没有健康保险。
But the pain wasn't going anywhere, and I was like, I can't be in a prayer position naked for two weeks. So I finally decide, after about-- it's probably 12:45 in the morning now. I decide, I can't take this anymore, something's wrong, I have to go to the hospital. And so, I get dressed. And I immediately hail a cab, so that was lucky. And the driver is like, where you going? And I was like-- I can barely speak-- I was like, the emergency room, please.
但痛苦并没有消失，我想，我不能光着身子以祈祷姿势待两周。所以最终我决定，大约是凌晨12:45。我决定，我不能再忍受了，出了点问题，我必须去医院。所以，我穿好衣服。我立刻叫了一辆出租车，那真是幸运。司机说，你要去哪？我说——我几乎说不出话——我说，急诊室，拜托。
And he was like, which one? And I was like, do you want me to yelp it? Make sure you take me to one with outdoor seating. I just want to go to the closest one. How about the closest one, because it's an emergency room.
他说，哪一个？我说，你想让我用 Yelp 搜一下吗？确保你带我去一个有户外座位的地方。我只想去最近的一个。最近的一个怎么样，因为那是急诊室。
So he takes me to the closest emergency room, which is Beth Israel Hospital. And of course, the waiting area is packed. And I even see a guy with, like, he's literally holding his T-shirt to his head and there's blood everywhere coming out of his head. And my thought was, great! Seriously, dude?
所以他带我去最近的急诊室，贝斯以色列医院。当然，候诊区挤满了人。我甚至看到一个家伙，他字面上在用T恤按着头，头上有血流得到处都是。我的想法是，太棒了！认真的吗，兄弟？
So I go over to the guy that's, like, in charge of who gets to live. And I'm like, sir-- this is the only words I get out of my mouth-- I go, stomach. And this guy is a mid-50s man that obviously has been working in this position for a long time. He's seen everything. And he looks at me, and he goes, go right ahead. And that's when I was like, crap. Because if anyone can see the aura of death on a person, it's that guy.
所以我走到负责决定谁能活下去的那个人面前。我说，先生——这是我嘴里能说出的唯一话——我说，胃。那家伙是个50多岁的人，显然在这个位置工作了很长时间。他什么都见过。他看着我，说，直接进去吧。那时候我心想，完了。因为如果有人能看到一个人身上的死亡光环，那就是那家伙。
So I go in and I get on a bed, and a guy comes over to me, a doctor comes over to me. And I go, my stomach, it's like I'm in so much pain I can't even describe it. And he was like, OK, all right, how about on a scale of one to 10, how would you rate your pain? And I was like, seven, because I'm saving 10 just in case.
所以我进去躺在床上，一个家伙走过来，一个医生走过来。我说，我的胃，那种痛到我无法描述。他说，好的，好的，如果按1到10分评分，你给你的痛苦评几分？我说，7分，因为我把10分留着以防万一。
And he says, oh, seven, that's very high. So he goes, OK, you gotta lay back. And so, I lay back and that hurts a lot. And he goes, OK, I'm going to press on your stomach. So he takes his hand and he pushes on my stomach. And the weird thing is, when he pushed on my stomach, my first thought was, 10. And so he goes, I'm going to get working on getting you some morphine.
他说，哦，7分，那是非常高了。他说，好吧，你得躺下。于是我躺下，那痛得厉害。他说，好的，我要按一下你的胃。于是他用手按我的胃。奇怪的是，当他按我的胃时，我的第一个想法是，10分。于是他说，我要去给你弄点吗啡。
And even though I'm in a lot of pain, I realize that, basically, I'm about to receive morphine, based on my word? My face must really be convincing right now. It's almost, that was as easy as, like, when a guy's in the park, like, got that morphine. So I'm nervous at this point, because for the previous 10 years I had been a raging alcoholic, drug addict. And I quit. I'd been sober for about a year and a half at this point. And he was going to give me morphine, which I'd never done when I was drinking and doing drugs, but it just didn't come up. But now it was and I was nervous.
即使我痛得要命，我也意识到，基本上，我就要得到吗啡了，就凭我的话？我的脸现在一定非常有说服力。几乎就像是在公园里一样容易，像是“那儿有吗啡”。那时候我很紧张，因为在过去的10年里，我曾是个狂热的酗酒者、吸毒者。我戒了。在那一刻我已经清醒了大约一年半。他要给我吗啡，我在喝酒和吸毒时从未尝试过，只是当时没碰到。但现在是了，我感到紧张。
So he gives me the morphine. And luckily, when you're in that much pain, morphine doesn't make you high. It just makes the pain like you can deal with it. So that was a relief, because I didn't want to think it was awesome. Because now I knew how to get it.
所以他给了我吗啡。幸运的是，当你痛到那种程度时，吗啡不会让你兴奋。它只是让痛苦变得可以忍受。这是一种解脱，因为我不想觉得它很棒。因为现在我知道怎么搞到它了。
So I'm on morphine and I'm feeling better. And he's like, all right, we're going to give you an MRI. Puts me in an MRI. They wheel me back out. And he comes over to me a few minutes later, and he says, the good news is you don't have kidney stones, so you won't be passing stones through your penis. That's literally what he said to me. He goes, unfortunately, the MRI has shown that your appendix has burst. We need to get you on powerful antibiotics very quickly.
所以我在用吗啡，感觉好多了。他说，好的，我们要给你做个核磁共振。把我放进核磁共振仪里。几分钟后把我推出来。他走过来对我说，好消息是你没有肾结石，所以你不需要通过阴茎排出结石。他字面上就是这么对我说的。他说，不幸的是，核磁共振显示你的阑尾破裂了。我们需要尽快给你用强效抗生素。
When your appendix bursts, there's all kinds of inflammatory poison going through your abdomen, and it is messing up everything, every organ in your body is getting inflamed by this poison and they need to make it settle down right away. They can't go in and do surgery because everything's too riled up, it's too dangerous. So I'm going to be on antibiotics, on an IV drip, without food, for four days.
当你的阑尾破裂时，各种炎症毒素会在你的腹部传播，它在搞乱一切，你身体里的每个器官都被这些毒素炎症感染，他们需要立即让它平息下来。他们不能进去做手术，因为一切都太混乱了，太危险了。所以我得在静脉滴注抗生素，不吃饭，待四天。
Most people who go to the hospital for an appendix go for an inflamed appendix that has not burst, and they can take it out before it bursts. My appendix burst, obviously, inside my body, which is definitely the worst place. And then I started thinking, and I realized that the appendix is the only organ in our body that doesn't have a job to do, but it's the first one to be like, screw this [MAKES BURSTING SOUND].
大多数去医院看阑尾的人是因为阑尾炎还没有破裂，他们可以在破裂前把它切除。我的阑尾明显在我的身体里破裂了，那绝对是最糟糕的地方。然后我开始想，我意识到阑尾是我们身体里唯一没有工作的器官，但它是第一个像，“去你的”[发出破裂声]的那一个。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Which seems very entitled, because I have organs in my body that have obviously had every right to walk off the job years ago due to unfair working conditions. My liver had been pumping poison out of my body at an astounding rate for years without complaining once, like a migrant worker just happy to have a job in America. Meanwhile, my appendix is like some spoiled NYU kid that never had to work a goddamned day in its life.
这看起来非常有优越感，因为我的身体里有些器官显然有充分的理由因为不公平的工作条件而在多年前就罢工了。我的肝脏多年来一直在以惊人的速度从我体内泵出毒素，没有抱怨过一次，就像一个为能在美国拥有一份工作而感到高兴的移民劳工。与此同时，我的阑尾就像那种从没干过一天活的被宠坏的纽约大学孩子。
And I can picture my liver being like, hey, appendix, can you help us out for a second? My appendix being like, uh, my dad owns, like [MAKES BURSTING SOUND].
我可以想象我的肝脏说，嘿，阑尾，你能帮我们一下吗？我的阑尾就像，呃，我爸拥有，比如[发出破裂声]。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So they finally, on the fourth night, I go into surgery at, like, 2:00 AM. I come out of it, and I'm like, Doctor, I really want to go home. And he's like, oh, yeah, you can't leave until you have a bowel movement. And I was like, this is the weirdest standoff I've ever had.
所以第四天晚上，我在凌晨2点左右做了手术。手术后，我说，医生，我真的很想回家。他说，哦，是的，你必须排便后才能离开。我说，这是我经历过的最奇怪的对峙。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Eventually, I do. I get home. And what you should be wondering-- if I were you, I would be wondering this-- how much? Right? No health insurance, seven days in the hospital, emergency appendectomy. Well, I'll tell you. It was $45,000. And I found out when I got a bill in the mail for $45,000. By the way, in the mail with the other mail, like it was just more mail, but it was a bill for $45,000, in a white envelope like all the other envelopes.
最终，我做到了。我回家了。你该问的问题——如果我是你，我会问这个——多少钱？对吧？没有健康保险，在医院待了七天，紧急阑尾切除术。好吧，我告诉你。是45,000美元。我是在邮件里收到45,000美元的账单时发现的。顺便说一下，是在其他邮件中，就像是又一封普通邮件，但那是一封45,000美元的账单，就像所有其他信封一样装在一个白信封里。
That should not come in a white envelope. That should come in a black envelope with a skull and crossbones on it, and when you open it, a picture of your hopes and dreams falls out and bursts into flames because now you owe the hospital $45,000.
那不应该装在白信封里。那应该装在一个带有骷髅交叉骨的黑信封里，当你打开它时，一张你希望和梦想的照片掉出来并烧毁，因为现在你欠医院45,000美元。
My friends had a lot of great financial advice. They were like, [BLEEP] 'em. Like, across the board. They were like, don't pay it. What are they going to do, put your appendix back in? And it was tempting, but I had to do it. I'm doing the right thing, because I was literally going to die and they saved my life. And it didn't feel right not paying them back.
我的朋友们有很多很棒的财务建议。他们说，[消音]他们。就像，全部。他们说，别付。他们能做什么，把你的阑尾装回去？这很诱人，但我不得不付。我在做正确的事，因为我真的快死了，他们救了我的命。不付钱给他们感觉不对。
So I am doing the right thing. And today, I am still paying them back, $20 a month. And if Beth Israel Hospital ever wants to see $45,000, they just have to make sure I live to be 657 years old, so ball's in your court, Beth Israel Hospital.
所以我正在做正确的事。今天，我还在付钱，一个月20美元。如果贝斯以色列医院想看到45,000美元，他们只需要确保我活到657岁，所以球在你们手里了，贝斯以色列医院。
Julian McCullough. HE performs pretty much every night of the week somewhere. To find out when he's showing up near you, julianmccullough.com. He was recorded at TOLD, which is a monthly storytelling show in New York City, hosted by our program's production manager, Seth Lind. They are at toldshow.com.
朱利安·麦卡洛。他几乎每周每天晚上都在某个地方表演。想知道他什么时候在附近演出，julianmccullough.com。他是在 TOLD 录制的，这是纽约市的一个每月故事讲述秀，由我们节目的制作经理塞斯·林德主持。他们在 toldshow.com。
[MUSIC - "I GET ALONG WITHOUT YOU VERY WELL" BY CHET BAKER]
[音乐 - 切特·贝克演唱的“我离开你过得很好” (I Get Along Without You Very Well)]
Act Three, Don't Make Me Separate You. Well we end our show today with this story about a family whose house was divided. Jeanne Darst was 16 when her parents split up, her three sisters just a little bit older. But her parents, Steve and Doris, did not do divorce like other people did.
第三幕，“别逼我把你们分开”。好了，我们今天以这个关于一个家庭的故事结束，他们的家庭破裂了。珍妮·达斯特16岁时父母离婚，三个姐妹比她大一点。但她的父母，史蒂夫和多丽丝，处理离婚的方式与其他人不同。
At first they acted like normal divorced people. They were angry, and they spoke badly of one another and dated other people and not each other. My mother could actually smell our father on us when we came in the door on Sunday night after a weekend at his place. "Have you been at your father's? You reek of franks and beans."
起初他们表现得像正常的离婚人士。他们很生气，互相说坏话，和别人约会而不是对方。周日晚上我们在父亲家过完周末回来时，我母亲甚至能闻到我们身上父亲的味道。“你们去过父亲那里了？你们身上臭得全是法兰克福香肠和豆子味儿。”
That first Thanksgiving they were divorced she forbid him to enter her apartment, so Dad took us to a sushi place on Third Avenue. Not a Calvin-Trillin-Chinatown-dumpling-house-on-Thanksgiving kind of place, but rather a last minute Dad-didn't-make-a-reservation-anywhere kind of place. It was empty, aka totally depressing and potentially gastro-disatrous. That Thanksgiving was the last time he ever took us out to dinner. He was quickly running out of money. It was the official start of destitute divorced dad.
他们离婚后的第一个感恩节，她禁止他进入她的公寓，所以爸爸带我们去了第三大道的一家寿司店。那不是那种卡尔文·特里林式唐人街饺子馆的感恩节地方，而是那种最后一分钟爸爸没预订到地方的地方。店里空荡荡的，也就是说极其令人沮丧，而且可能有消化灾难。那个感恩节是他最后一次带我们出去吃饭。他的钱很快就用光了。这是赤贫离婚爸爸的正式开始。
He was early to pick up my sisters and me for Christmas. Ever since I can remember, my father never had anywhere else he had to be. He was sitting on one of the couches in the lobby of Mom's apartment building with a bag of presents on either side of his knees. He wore a hat. He still bought and wore hats, mostly from this prehistoric preppy store on Madison and 46th, FR Tripler. Tripler's was his only charge card so you could count on some things coming from there at Christmas.
他早早来接我和姐妹们过圣诞节。从我记事起，我父亲就从没别的地方可去。他坐在母亲公寓大堂的一张沙发上，膝盖两侧各有一个装礼物的袋子。他戴着帽子。他依然购买和佩戴帽子，主要是从麦迪逊大道和46街那家史前预科生商店，FR Tripler。Tripler's 是他唯一的信用卡，所以你可以指望圣诞节会有一些东西是从那里来的。
The men's section may have been possible, but the women's clothes were the most outdated, buttoned up, queer [BLEEP] imaginable. What old money wear in menopause. He got up and gave his usual huge greeting.
男装区可能还行，但女装却是最过时、扣得严严实实、极其古怪的[消音]东西。有钱老女人们在更年期穿的。他站起来，发出了他一贯的大声问候。
"Jeanne Jo, Carolina, Julita, Elizabetha, Merry Christmas! Sit! Sit! Have if I got some great things for you all!"
“珍妮·乔，卡罗琳娜，朱莉塔，伊丽莎白，圣诞快乐！坐！坐！看看我给你们准备了什么好东西！”
My dad, hat and grey overcoat still on, began taking presents out of the bags, all unwrapped. My father had never wrapped present. Ever. It totally threw off your timing as the person getting the gift, because you could plainly see what you were being given as he reached across people to hand it to you. And out of politeness, you had to maintain a facade of suspense as you passed the gift your way.
我父亲，帽子和大衣还没脱，开始从袋子里往外拿礼物，全都没包装。我父亲从没包过礼物。从来没有。这让作为礼物接受者的你很尴尬，因为当他越过别人递给你时，你可以清楚地看到你得到的是什么。而出于礼貌，当你传递礼物时，你必须保持一种悬念的假象。
There were biographies he got half price at the Strand, a button down shirt with a silk tie at the collar from Tripler's that Pat Buckley might wear to jury duty. And then the worst kind of present my dad gave, an expensive item like a fancy camera, that you knew meant he wasn't going to eat for a week.
有他在 Strand 书店半价买的传记，有领子上系着丝质领带的 Tripler's 衬衫，那种帕特·巴克利去参加陪审团义务时可能会穿的。还有我爸爸给的最糟糕的那种礼物，比如昂贵的相机，你知道那意味着他接下来一周都没饭吃了。
We sat in the lobby opening presents, thankful that because Mom was new to the building, we didn't know any of the people coming and going to their holiday festivities, passing us and giving a raised eyebrow to the doorman Mario. Liz and Caroline, the two people in our family who had incomes, entry-level though they were, made a couple overtures to actually going somewhere for brunch. But Dad cheerfully dismissed these wacky notions. "Oh, I think we're good right here," he said. My gift was heartbreakingly expensive, a brand new Oxford English Dictionary.
我们坐在大堂里拆礼物，很庆幸因为母亲刚搬进这栋楼，我们不认识任何来来去去过节的人，他们经过我们身边，向门房马里奥投去怀疑的目光。利兹和卡罗琳，我们家仅有的两个有收入的人，尽管是入门级，还是做出了几个想去吃早午餐的提议。但爸爸愉快地否决了这些古怪的想法。“哦，我觉得我们就待在这儿挺好的，”他说。我的礼物极其昂贵，一本全新的《牛津英语大辞典》。
"What do you think about that OED, Jeanne Jo?"
“你觉得这本 OED 怎么样，珍妮·乔？”
"It's wonderful."
“它很棒。”
"Your life as you know it, gone, I'm telling ya. You'll thank me later."
“你所知道的生活，已经过去了，我告诉你。以后你会感谢我的。”
"Thanks, Dad."
“谢谢，爸爸。”
"You're very welcome."
“别客气。”
My father then reached into one of his bags and pulled out a large hunk of Parmesan cheese.
我父亲随后伸手进袋子，拿出一大块帕尔马干酪。
"I thought my bio of Rebecca West smelled a little funny," Liz giggled.
“我还以为我那本丽贝卡·韦斯特的传记闻起来有点怪呢，”利兹咯咯笑道。
"Murray's cheese shop on Bleecker," Dad said.
“布里克街的默里奶酪店，”爸爸说。
He pulled a knife out of his herringbone overcoat and chiseled off a flaky hunk.
他从人字呢大衣里掏出一把刀，凿下一大块片状的奶酪。
"Caroline, can I interest you in some of the finest of Parma?"
“卡罗琳，我有兴趣请你尝尝这最优质的帕尔马奶酪吗？”
Caroline, on the verge of tears, uttered, "No thank you."
卡罗琳快要哭出来了，说道：“不，谢谢。”
"All right then. Terrible decision but you're free to make it. Elizabetha?"
“好吧。可怕的决定，但你自由选择。伊丽莎白？”
"Sure," she said, "yummy."
“好的，”她说，“真美味。”
He handed Liz the crumbly cheese. "Help yourself to some of that good bread. Now who else would like a bit? Julia, what's the name of that doorman again?"
他把松脆的奶酪递给利兹。“去拿点那种好面包吧。还有谁想尝尝？朱莉，那个门房叫什么名字来着？”
"Mario, but he doesn't want any cheese, Dad," Julie said.
“马里奥，但他不想吃奶酪，爸爸，”朱莉说。
"Nonsense. It's Christmas and he's working. Where's your spirit?"
“胡说。今天是圣诞节，他在工作。你的精神去哪了？”
"Please don't offer him any cheese, Dad," Caroline pleaded.
“求求你别给他奶酪，爸爸，”卡罗琳恳求道。
"What is wrong with you girls?" My dad stood up and yelled across the lobby, "Mario! Mario!" my father bellowed. Mario put his Daily News down. "Can I interest you in some of the finest Parmesan this side of the Mediterranean?"
“你们女孩到底怎么了？”我爸爸站起来在大厅对面大喊，“马里奥！马里奥！”我父亲咆哮道。马里奥放下了他的《每日新闻》。“我有兴趣请你尝尝地中海这边最优质的帕尔马奶酪吗？”
"Oh. No thank you, sir."
“哦。不，谢谢，先生。”
"You're not being polite are you, Mario?"
“你不够礼貌，是吗，马里奥？”
"Dad, he doesn't want any cheese," I said.
“爸爸，他不想吃奶酪，”我说。
"O.K., I will have some," Mario said. "Thank you."
“好吧，那我吃一点，”马里奥说。“谢谢。”
"Terrific. OK, let's see here," and my dad began jabbing at the Parmesan with his knife. "Whare are you from Mario?"
“太棒了。好的，来看看，”我爸爸开始用刀戳帕尔马奶酪。“你是哪儿人，马里奥？”
"Italy."
“意大利。”
"What part?" My dad placed a chunk of cheese in Mario's palm.
“哪部分？”我爸爸把一块奶酪放在马里奥手心里。
"Umbria."
“翁布里亚。”
"Umbria. My god, that's gorgeous land. Your family farmers or winemakers or what?" My dad nibbled on a piece of cheese as if he were at a cocktail party in Southampton.
“翁布里亚。天哪，那可是美得不得了的地方。你们家里是农民还是酿酒师还是什么的？”我爸爸细嚼慢咽着奶酪，仿佛他在南安普顿的鸡尾酒会上一样。
Just then, the doors of one of the two elevators opened and Mom and Phil Sully got off. Phil was her divorce lawyer. She was also sleeping with him. They walked into the lobby. Mom's eyes went to the cheese on the lobby table, the presents everywhere, the crumbling baguette on the table, Dad, Mario, and us girls. While it didn't reflect favorably upon Dad, it wasn't what you'd call a moment of glory for Mom or Phil Sully either.
就在这时，两部电梯的门开了，母亲和菲尔·萨利走了出来。菲尔是她的离婚律师。她也正和他睡觉。他们走进大厅。母亲的目光转向大厅桌子上的奶酪、到处散落的礼物、桌上碎掉的法棍面包、爸爸、马里奥，还有我们几个女孩。虽然这对爸爸的评价不太好，但对母亲或菲尔·萨利来说也不算什么光彩的时刻。
Mom simply walked through it like a rain shower. "Steve," she said. "Girls." Mario trotted to the door and held it open for them as they walked out of the lobby into the sharp December chill and 87th Street.
母亲只是穿过了它，就像一阵阵雨。“史蒂夫，”她说。“女孩们。”马里奥小跑到门口为她们开门，她们走出了大厅，走进了87街刺骨的12月寒风中。
A few months later Mom decided to ditch the Upper East Side for Florida which seemed like a gutsy divorced lady starting over kind of move. My parents were physically further apart than they'd ever been. But then there was some backpedaling. Mom was asked to leave the complex she lived in the Sunshine State after only a few months at which point she opted to crash in the West Village at my father's studio while she looked for her own place.
几个月后，母亲决定离开上东区前往佛罗里达，这看起来像是勇敢离婚女士重新开始的一种举动。我的父母在物理距离上比以往任何时候都远。但后来又有一些反复。母亲在阳光之州住了几个月后就被要求离开，随后她选择住在父亲位于西村的工作室里，同时寻找她自己的住处。
My parents now ate together, went to movies, and checked each other in and out of the hospital. Some people might call this dating. She delivered the news over the phone. "Hi, Dolly, it's Mom. I'm at your father's," she said. "I've left Florida." She paused letting her line land, as they say in the theater.
我的父母现在一起吃饭，一起去看电影，并互相照顾着进出医院。有些人可能会称此为约会。她通过电话传达了这个消息。“嗨，多莉，是我。我在你父亲那里，”她说。“我离开佛罗里达了。”她停顿了一下，让这行台词落地，就像戏剧里说的那样。
The problem with my mother was that everything she said had a big landing. "I'm no longer on speaking terms with my hairdresser" went high into the air and came down at your feet with as much of a thud as "they found a growth the size of a brioche under my left armpit." The last time I spoke with her mother said she was doing OK, that she missed minorities terribly.
我母亲的问题在于她所说的每一句话都有一个很大的着陆点。“我不再和我的理发师说话了”这句话高高飞起，然后重重地落在你脚下，发出和“他们在我的左腋窝下发现了一个布里欧修面包大小的肿瘤”一样的重击声。最后一次我跟她说话，母亲说她做得很好，她非常想念少数群体。
"You left Florida because you missed black people?" I asked.
“你离开佛罗里达是因为你想念黑人吗？”我问。
"Not just black people, Jeanne. Gays and Latinos and the Chinese and the Koreans."
“不仅仅是黑人，珍妮。还有同性恋、拉丁裔、中国人和韩国人。”
"Lesbians?" I asked.
“女同性恋？”我问。
"Actually, I've never thought lesbians add that much to the city frankly. Anyway, I'm at your father's. He's being absolutely impossible."
“事实上，坦白说，我从来没觉得女同性恋对这个城市有什么贡献。总之，我在你父亲这里。他表现得绝对不可能。”
"Really?" I asked. What did she expect? They were married for 23 years, but this week, this is the one that did it?
“真的吗？”我问。她期待什么？他们结婚了23年，但这一周，这就是导致一切的那一周？
"I slept on a bed with no sheets last night," she said. "And did you know your father sometimes sleeps upright in his computer chair?"
“昨晚我睡在一张没有床单的床上，”她说。“还有你知道你父亲有时直挺挺地睡在他的电脑椅上吗？”
"Why?"
“为什么？”
"Apparently his asthma is so bad that he has to sleep upright to be able to breathe."
“显然他的哮喘太严重了，他必须直立睡觉才能呼吸。”
"Why doesn't he prop some pillows up in bed?"
“他为什么不在床上垫几个枕头？”
"He's afraid he'll stop breathing if he does that." I hear my mother light a cigarette and exhale.
“他怕他那样做的话呼吸会停止。”我听到我母亲点燃了一支烟并呼出烟雾。
"Are you smoking in his house?"
“你在他家里抽烟吗？”
"Oh, he's not hear right now."
“哦，他现在不在这儿。”
After two days of Mom staying with Dad, my sister Caroline calls me from Saint Vincent's Hospital.
在母亲和爸爸待了两天后，我的姐妹卡罗琳从圣文森特医院打电话给我。
"Hi. So Dad had a major asthma attack." I visit the hospital and see him. He'd nearly died. And to keep him alive, the doctors gave him massive doses of several drugs, steroids being the big one. Which, the nurse tells me, is why he threw a heavy hospital chair out his window the night before, landing on 7th Avenue.
“嗨。爸爸哮喘大发作了。”我去医院看他。他差点死了。为了让他活下来，医生给他开了大剂量的几种药物，类固醇是主要的。护士告诉我，这就是为什么他前天晚上把一把沉重的医院椅子扔出窗外，落在了第七大道上。
I asked Dad whether Mom smoking in his house might have brought on the asthma attack. He says he hadn't thought about that but admitted it was a possibility. He recovers after a few days and I see him for Caroline's birthday.
我问爸爸母亲在他家抽烟是否引发了哮喘发作。他说他没想过这一点，但承认这是一种可能。几天后他康复了，我因为卡罗琳的生日去见他。
We go to Dad's little studio. With its tiny sink and half ridge under the counter it feels like Gregor Samsa's Winnebago. The main room was approximately 12 feet by 12 feet.
我们去了爸爸那个小工作室。由于有微小的水槽和柜台下半个冰箱，它感觉就像格雷戈尔·萨姆沙的温尼巴格房车。主房间大约12英尺乘12英尺。
Six of us gathered as best we could in the space that had one chair and a reclined futon, and Dad brought Caroline's birthday cake out of the mini fridge. "Now this place is terrific. The best," he said, putting the cake on the desk. It was from Claude's. Claude's was the best. And expensive, which is why we were a little shocked.
六个人尽可能地聚集在这个只有一个椅子和折叠躺椅的空间里，爸爸从迷你冰箱里拿出了卡罗琳的生日蛋糕。“这个地方太棒了。最好，”他说，把蛋糕放在桌子上。这是 Claude's 的。Claude's 是最好的。而且很贵，这就是我们有点震惊的原因。
"Steve, how about a cake knife?" Mom said, trying to help things along.
“史蒂夫，来把切蛋糕的刀怎么样？”母亲说，试图推进事情。
"A what?"
“什么？”
"A cake knife and some plates?"
“一把蛋糕刀和几个盘子？”
"Absolutely. Absolutely," Dad headed back into the kitchen where he rummaged around. He returned with a knife and three plates for six people. No forks. He handed the knife to Caroline. Everyone watched Caroline opened the white box.
“绝对的。绝对的，”爸爸回到厨房，他在那里翻找。他回来时带着一把刀和三个盘子，给六个人用。没有叉子。他把刀递给卡罗琳。每个人都看着卡罗琳打开白盒子。
"Dad!" Caroline screamed. "There's a piece missing!"
“爸爸！”卡罗琳尖叫道。“少了一块！”
"Oh for God's sake, Steve," Mom gasped.
“天哪，史蒂夫，”母亲倒吸一口凉气。
"It was half price with a piece missing. We don't need that piece. To hell with that piece!"
“少了一块半价。我们不需要那块。去它的那块！”
Mom got up. "I'm going outside for a cigarette."
母亲站了起来。“我去外面抽支烟。”
Caroline remain speechless looking at the birthday cake with a piece missing. my sister Julia and I headed downstairs to smoke with Mom.
卡罗琳保持沉默，看着少了一块的生日蛋糕。我的姐妹朱莉和我下楼去陪母亲抽烟。
"Honestly." Mom took a puff and watched a large gay man move past us with his Lhasa Apso. "A birthday cake with a piece missing. I could kill him."
“真是的。”母亲吸了一口烟，看着一个高大的同性恋男子带着他的拉萨犬走过我们身边。“少了一块的生日蛋糕。我能杀了他。”
"Or you could stay somewhere else," I offered up.
“或者你可以住别的地方，”我提议。
"Yeah, Mom, you don't have to put up with his crap," Julia said.
“是的，妈妈，你不需要忍受他的烂事，”朱莉说。
"Right. And well you don't have put up with his crap because you are in fact no longer married," I said, trying once more to convey the basic concept of divorce to these two. Who seemed not to understand that a significant part of divorce entailed not seeing each other.
“对。好吧，你不需要忍受他的烂事，因为事实上你们已经不再结婚了，”我说，试图再一次向这两个人传达离婚的基本概念。她们似乎不明白离婚的一个重要部分包括不互相见面。
And then my mother revealed that she had signed a lease on an apartment across 8th Avenue on Greenwich Street a few weeks earlier. She could have moved into her own apartment weeks before Caroline's birthday. Weeks before she put Dad in the emergency room at Saint Vincent's.
然后我母亲透露她在几周前签了一份第八大道对面格林威治街公寓的租约。她本可以在卡罗琳生日的几周前搬进她自己的公寓。在她把爸爸送进圣文森特医院急诊室的前几周。
"I can't possibly stay here one more minute." She lit a new cigarette and exhaled defensively. "I'm not married the man you know."
“我一分钟也待不下去了。”她点燃了一支新烟，防卫性地呼出烟雾。“你知道的，我并没有和他结婚。”
"That's what I've been trying to say."
“我一直在试着说这个。”
They continued on this way for years. They had sold the house, moved into the city, gotten separate places, tried dating other people. And apparently, it just wasn't for them. From my mother's perspective, they were in no way getting remarried or even back together. She was almost a little secretive about the whole way they lived.
她们就这样继续了多年。她们卖掉了房子，搬进城里，找了不同的住处，尝试和别人约会。显然，这不适合她们。从我母亲的角度来看，她们绝不是要再婚，甚至不是回到一起。她对她们生活的整个方式几乎有点保密。
When she mentioned something my father had said, I'd say, "Oh, when did he say that?"
当她提到父亲说过的话时，我会问：“哦，他什么时候说的？”
"Oh, the other night. He brought me some cigarettes. It was awfully cold from me to go out." Long pause. Then ultra casually, "And he ended up staying and watching some TV over here."
“哦，前天晚上。他给我带了一些烟。我出去太冷了。”长时间停顿。然后极其随意地，“他最后留下来在我这儿看了会儿电视。”
"Oh really?" I always wanted to say, "Mom has a new boyfriend. Mom has a new boyfriend." Neither of them was ever able to move on in any part of their lives. They could drive each other insane and do awful things to each other. At one point, my mother convinced my father to move back in with her and then when he went out one night for an ink cartridge for his computer, she locked him out and wouldn't him back in.
“哦，真的吗？”我一直想说，“妈妈有新男朋友了。妈妈有新男朋友了。”他们俩在生活的任何部分都无法向前看。他们能把对方逼疯，对彼此做可怕的事情。有一次，我母亲说服我父亲搬回她那里住，然后当他有一天晚上出门买电脑墨盒时，她把他锁在门外，不让他回去。
They often broke up within their divorce-- a divorce within a divorce-- but they can never truly leave each other. My father was and still is profoundly protective of my mother. This is why he wouldn't blame his asthma attack on her smoking. She too somehow needed him. And though she divorced him, she still allowed him to come by, to love her. And until she died, she never really left him.
他们经常在离婚中分手——离婚中的离婚——但他们永远无法真正离开彼此。我父亲一直并将继续深刻地保护我母亲。这就是为什么他不会把哮喘发作归咎于她的吸烟。她也以某种方式需要他。尽管她和他离婚了，但她仍然允许他过来，爱她。直到她去世，她从未真正离开他。
"Your mother and I have a failed divorce," my father said to me once over greasy eggs at a luncheonette. "We gave it our best shot. We really did. It just didn't work out."
“你母亲和我有一场失败的离婚，”我父亲曾经在一家小餐馆吃着油腻的鸡蛋时对我说道。“我们尽力了。我们真的尽力了。只是没成功。”
Jeanne Darst, reading an excerpt adapted from her book, Fiction Ruined My Family, which comes out this coming October.
珍妮·达斯特，阅读改编自她即将于10月出版的书《小说毁了我的家庭》(Fiction Ruined My Family)的节选。
[MUSIC - "DYSFUNCTIONAL" BY HONEYCUT]
[音乐 - HONEYCUT 演唱的“功能失调” (Dysfunctional)]
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Eric Mennel. Music help from Jessica Hopper and Damian Grathe. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager. Jen Berman's filling in as our west coast producer.
我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助由埃里克·门内尔提供。音乐协助由杰西卡·霍珀和达米安·格拉斯提供。塞斯·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米莉·康顿是我们的办公室经理。简·伯曼在代班我们的西海岸制片人。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who want you to know he loves black people.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。我们 WBEZ 电台的托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责我们节目的管理监督，他想让你知道他爱黑人。
Not just black people. Gays, and Latinos, and the Chinese, and the Koreans.
不仅仅是黑人。同性恋、拉丁裔、中国人、韩国人。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。